[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
48 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
Thanks, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty good.
Pretty good.
Very happy to be recording
in a room with no lights.
Because we discussed last time
that someone broke the door.
Well, someone broke the lights.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's a very dark room.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it's
pretty romantic, to be honest.
So very happy today
to have-- yeah,
very happy to have the first
Spaniard in the podcast.
She's Ines Envid, Ines
Envid-- since I can actually
pronounce it in Spanish,
I know how to do that--
and she's a product manager
in the Cloud Networking team
for the Google Cloud Platform.
And we're going to be
talking about, basically,
all the things you can
do with the network
and why Google Cloud Platform
network is so amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, no,
it's a really great chat.
I know so little about VPCs
and VPNs, and other things
of that nature that it's
great to sit down and talk
to someone who actually knows
what that stuff is here.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, this was one
of the episodes where I
learned the most, basically,
because I didn't have
much of an idea of what
you could do with it.
I know TCP and GDP.
That's pretty much it.
I know what they mean.
MARK MANDEL: You
know what they mean?
Good.
That's good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, don't ask me.
So and after that,
after the chat,
we'll have the question
of the week, which
is also related to networking.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
actually, that
was completely non-intentional,
but it actually
works really well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's going
to be about network
load balancers
and some weird protocols
I had never heard about.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
the Proxy Protocol.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The Proxy Protocol
and how to use it on a network
load balancer Google Cloud
platform.
But before that, we have
the Cool Thing of the Week.
And as usual, I think,
yeah, it's renamed
the Cool Things of the Week.
So the first one is we put
a cable down somewhere,
we install a cable.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's a really big cable
of internet goodness that
goes between Hong Kong and Los
Angeles, this Pacific
Light Cable Network.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And it is
12,800 kilometers of cable
that allows you to send
120 terabits per second,
which is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, you consume
a lot of Netflix over that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you can stream the
Netflix per second, basically.
It is pretty amazing.
So yeah, that's going to help a
lot on people that are doing--
if you have a server, one in
LA, another one in Hong Kong,
the connection now is
going to be pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
On top of that, there's a really
great article for our .NET
users out there.
There is a maintain
containerized ASP.NET Core
apps with Kubernetes.
I quite like this one,
especially because now that
.NET Core is open source,
you can run it on Linux,
which is super cool, which means
you can run it on all the stuff
that's on top of Linux,
including Docker and container
orchestration.
So it's a really
cool little article
that talks you through how
to build Docker containers.
You can actually use the
standard Microsoft .NET Docker
container you can
get off Docker Hub,
and then how to build your
projects on top of that,
and then finally get it into
Kubernetes and Container
Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
is definitely taking also--
if you have never
tried, you can actually
run Windows in a container,
which is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: That's amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's something
that if you're interested
on Windows in containers,
you should definitely
check it out.
I thought you were going to
say that you especially liked
this post because it was written
by someone from our team,
[? Mehti. ?]
MARK MANDEL: I
totally missed that.
That is cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It is actually
written by [? Mehti. ?] Maybe
we should interview him
to have a .NET episode.
MARK MANDEL: We should.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
should to that, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We should
absolutely do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
we have one last Cool
Thing of the Week, which
is that we are hiring.
So Google Cloud Platform,
we have a pretty big team--
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --I
got to say, and we're
hiring like crazy for
basically everything.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, account
executives, sales engineers,
solution architects, engineers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
But also, technical
leads and account executives.
No, you said account executives.
I think that also for marketing.
And we're basically
hiring for everything.
So if you would like to
work with us, check it out.
We'll have a link to the
Careers page on the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: And in theory,
if you come work on Cloud,
you could one day
be on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If you
don't work on Cloud,
you could also be
on the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: That's also true.
That is fair.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
But yeah, you could get to
get lunch with us regularly,
which is actually pretty cool.
OK, so I think that it's
time to go talk with Ines.
MARK MANDEL: I think so.
Let's do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I'm very happy today
to welcome our first Spaniard
to the Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
She's Ines Envid, and
she's a product manager
for Cloud Networking.
Hello, Ines.
How are you doing?
INES ENVID: Hi.
Doing great.
How are you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very
happy to have you.
So we're going to be talking
about many different things.
Networking is a very,
very wide topic.
But before we get
started, why don't you
tell us a little bit about you
and what do you do at Google.
INES ENVID: Sure.
So I've been a
long-term technology
person working in networking.
So I've been doing a lot
of enterprise and carrier,
working from Access
to Edge to Backbone.
And I've been transitioning
to a public cloud,
and I'm so excited to be now
part of Google, where we're
building one of the most amazing
infrastructures and products
in the planet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So can you tell us a little bit,
so from a very, very high point
of view, what is networking?
Like, machines talking
together to each other,
but what do you do with
networking, really?
INES ENVID: So yeah,
you have machines,
and that's a good
starting point,
but you cannot do much unless
you are able to actually give
them a channel to talk.
So networking is all about
making that communication
efficient and flexible
so that you can actually
build topology that
is allowing, only
the most primitive
types of communication
machine to machine,
but you're actually
able to build your multicast,
your broadcast environments.
So it is a way of
providing the plumbing,
if you wish, for machines
so that we can actually
build richer applications
on top of them.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I guess there sounds
like there's probably
almost several
components to networking.
There's the hardware side
that runs in our data center
and then there's the software
side that probably we
talk about as well as GCP.
Why don't we start
the hardware side?
What makes our stuff good?
What's so special about
the network that we run on?
INES ENVID: Sure.
So traditionally, networking has
been running in dedicated boxes
and everything was
really about having
dedicated ASICs, dedicated FPA.
So it's very
hardware-oriented and that
build, in the last decades,
great technology, which
was deployed
on-premises, was deployed
at the edge and the backbones.
And those machines, bridges,
routers, load balancers,
they kept developing,
and of course,
the requirements on performance,
on functional capabilities just
are more and more demanding.
But also as part of that
evolution, in the last year,
it has been very exciting,
all the transition about being
able to actually run those in
more, not dedicated hardware,
but more hardware
that is used for any
of the compute functions
today can actually
be used to build great
networking equipment.
So together with the trend to
have a lot more distributed
environment, because
what allows, actually,
to have the performance is
that you are not bottlenecked
to a single box, where you would
actually have great hardware
to run it, but
then you can start
distributing those
functions, and then you
need a lot of logic
in order to do that.
And what it makes Google
infrastructure great
is that it has been investing
on data center, which actually
provide all the distribution
across the globe, where you are
actually be able to send
your traffic as needed
and distribute it
to the right points
closest to the
applications where
it makes more sense for
latency and for performance.
And of course, Google
has been building
on that to deploy different
[? talents ?] and the back-ends
for all the search and YouTube
and all the infrastructure.
So leveraging on that
is also a starting point
for building Cloud functions.
So that is really, I
think, the best asset
the Google Cloud
is able to leverage
that great infrastructure and
provide the secure environment
for users to build their
applications the same way
that Google has actually
built their infrastructure
applications.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So you said two words
that I almost understood.
At least I knew one
of them was ASIC,
which we used before once,
which it is Application-Specific
Integrated Circuit.
You also said FPA?
INES ENVID: Oh, FPA.
It's similar.
It's hardware purpose-built
for networking functions
where you actually do
lookups for packets.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Interesting.
INES ENVID: You
apply firewall rules.
So it is really a very efficient
way of processing packets
that it was necessary,
really, in the past
in order to provide good
performance for networking
capabilities.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I was wondering if
you could discuss
one of the-- every
single time someone talks
about Google networking,
there is always
Jupiter that comes
out, like, that really
cool and powerful
magic, basically, thing.
What is that exactly and
why is it so important?
INES ENVID: So
Jupiter is actually
just a fabric that is really
providing high capabilities
in terms of bandwidth
and performance,
and it really is built by having
very flexible modules that
communicate with each other.
And modularizing that and
being able to scale it
provides a way for communicating
data centers in a way
that we don't have
bottlenecks in the network.
So it is just basically a
highly scalable architecture
for networking.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Just that.
INES ENVID: Just that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No,
that's pretty amazing.
The fact that the network
is not the bottleneck,
that is pretty impressive.
Cool.
So it is really
impressive that we
have all of that
amazing infrastructure
to build applications on top
by running a Google Cloud
platform.
But from a more pragmatical
point of view, what can I do?
Like, if I have my
virtual machines, right?
My virtual machines, I
just start them and they
can communicate to each other.
What else should I do?
INES ENVID: Right.
So let me then get
started, now that we've
talked a little bit about the
infrastructure, the first thing
that customers can actually,
or users can leverage
on the infrastructure
is the fact
that that network is global.
Global mean, we at Google have
our own backbone infrastructure
with the dedicated links.
So it is our own
network-- actually,
there's two of
them-- that are just
dedicated for Google to
communicate their data center.
So based on that, users
can build their sandboxes
with a global scope, which is
very unique in the industry,
because you can have your
private RFC 1918 space, which
is the private IP space,
spanning all around the globe.
So you can do very
unique things,
like having database
replication across regions
or providing things like
global load balancing, which
allows you to have your
back-ends distributed
across regions for
redundancy purposes.
And we provide some
very unique technologies
to have a single [INAUDIBLE]
for load balancing
that it sends you
via a technology
that we call Anycast
to the closest cluster
where you have
your applications.
So that actually provides
you the best of both worlds.
A very global scope,
while when you're actually
making a request, it
sends you to the closest
point for latency purposes.
So the first thing is global.
Second thing is
you start building
your security on top of that.
Once you have decided
where you need
to have your applications,
that you need to make sure
that they're secure.
And in order for
them to make secure,
your build your
firewalls on top of that.
Those are all networking
functions that are implemented.
Going back to the first
part of the conversation,
they are built at the
host level, so truly,
truly distributed so that they
don't provide any bottlenecks
to your network while they're
securing your applications
right at the point
where they live,
so that you can set up
your firewalls for how
those applications
can communicate.
Your user interface is [? do ?]
applied at your network level,
but when it actually
gets applied,
then it goes to the host where
your applications are living,
so they get secure
at that same point.
So you have your global network.
You have your firewalls
built on top of that, that
will give you your security.
Then you need to connect to
the rest of your application.
So most of the use cases will
involve having to transition,
migrate from existing
capabilities.
So you need things like
VPN, which we fully
manage as well, as a service,
in order to connect securely
with your on-premises and you
can federate your environment.
So it is really
great starting point
for building your sandbox.
And then on top of that,
there's plenty of applications
that we can talk
about, but that is
kind of the topology
plumbing, security aspect
of your sandbox, where
you can then just
build anything you need.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
That sounds great.
But I know we have a variety
of tools and products,
like VPNs, you were talking
about, load balancers,
but as well as a whole
bunch of other stuff
that I, personally, don't know a
huge amount about what they do.
So why don't we take
a practical example?
So we have a web server.
It wants to talk to the outside
internet, so that's great,
but it also talks to a
database maybe hosted
on a VM or something,
but we don't
want that database
to be accessible
to the outside internet.
How would I set that up
using our networking tools?
INES ENVID: Oh, that's
a great example.
So first, you want to
make sure that you really
don't have access
to the internet
from the applications or the
VMs that they don't have to.
And the first thing
you can do, you
can actually protect that
with different layer,
which is always a good idea.
I think, first is,
you want to make sure
that you have firewall rules
that are actually not allowing
for any connections that
are coming from the outside
to actually reach that machine.
So we provide what we call
stateful firewalls, which
what it does is, really,
you set up a rule which
applies to the whole session.
So as soon as the
session requests comes,
if it matches a certain
pattern, then you allow or deny.
And then if you actually
deny that session,
like there's no
more chances for any
of their following up packets of
that session to actually enter.
So that provides a very easy
way of setting up the firewall.
So you can set up
other networking level
those type of rules.
And again, they could
apply to your host
where your database are living.
So it is, as well,
very scalable,
where you're actually
applying those.
The other thing that
you can actually do
is enforce that those
[? project ?] actually
doesn't have the capability of
having VMs with external IPs
at all.
So that will be an enforcement,
not so much on the user,
but it's actually trying
to change the behavior,
but at the project
level, so that regardless
of which role someone is using,
the enforcement, it is done.
So that will be
for the database.
And then obviously,
for your front-ends,
you have the
capabilities of pinging
just specifically the ports
for the web application
or specifically the ports
that you are trying to reach.
And if you're using capabilities
like HTTP load balancing,
then we provide
the proxy solution,
which, again, is the same that
Google uses for production,
so the front-ends are
the same and there
is very rich capabilities, for
instance, for DOS protection
in order to find
patterns that could
be possible attacks
for your application.
So if you're using Google's
load balancing as a service,
you get advantage, by default,
by all those rich capabilities
that are already there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So what you're saying is that
if I have a bunch of instances
that are running
my web server, just
by putting a load
balancer in front of them
to facilitate the access and
share just one single IP,
I'm also gaining that protection
against denial of service
and these kind of attacks.
INES ENVID: That's correct.
And--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
INES ENVID: --those
capabilities are, again,
the same that apply
to the external access
communication that happens for
any of the Google applications,
so leveraging on those existing
capabilities is a great asset.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What about VPCs?
I've heard about VPCs
many times and I'm
almost sure it means virtual
private-- what is the C?
I could have network.
INES ENVID: Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cloud.
Oh, right.
Oh, wow.
INES ENVID: Yeah, you build
a cloud, but it's virtual
and it's private, so it
all goes with advantages.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
are VPCs something
that could help on
what you were talking?
What is actually a
VPC and how could it
help make our solution safer?
INES ENVID: So the VPC, it's
really-- you can think of it,
again, I used the
term before, but you
can think of it as the
sandbox where you are actually
running your application.
So if you, as a user, have
your production environment,
your production
environment is going
to run in a private space.
You don't want to expose
it to the internet.
So those applications in
your production environment
are going to be talking
across each other.
You have rules that are going
to define how they actually
communicate and you have
your perimeter defined
for those applications.
Any communication
external, then,
is going to be controlled,
again, with firewall rules.
So it gives you private
space, like in an in-network,
and it will be a
private IP space where
you are mapping
your applications,
you are running your services
while you are securing
against the outside world.
And there are great ways
of leverage that sandbox
and that private IP applications
when you're actually
working in Google environment.
Some of them are,
for instance, access
to Google services like Storage
or big data or BigQuery, where
there is all the data
ingestion and data processing
capabilities.
You can actually access
those from your VPC,
which is, again, your private
environment, privately as well.
So that when you're
communicating your workloads
to get access to all the
APIs and service capabilities
that Google offer, think as well
about machine learning APIs.
So you do that in a secure
way via private communication.
So it's really a way
of building, truly,
your private cloud while
it is all virtualized,
because it gives you
the illusion that you
are running your
own infrastructure,
you're running
your own services.
But what it does is, of course,
gives you all the flexibility
of you need extra capacity.
You don't really need to worry
about bringing new hardware.
It gives you the illusion that
it's all your infrastructure.
You can actually
secure it and make sure
that it's not accessible
by anyone else.
Gives you the isolation
with the rest of the tenants
that, of course,
lives in Google Cloud,
but then you have all the
nice private capabilities.
MARK MANDEL: Now I'm
going to ask this question
and I could be totally
wrong, which is totally fine.
So does subnetworks
relate to VPCs?
INES ENVID: Right.
So the subnetworks, it will
be, if your VPC's your sandbox,
then you carve out IP
space in networking.
So it is the IP
range that is going
to be used for IP allocation
for certain applications.
So you just want to make
sure that if you're running,
let's say, in your case, you
were talking about web servers,
and you're working, you're
talking about databases,
you may want to have your web
servers having IPs allocated
from a specific
space, your database
is having IP ranges
from a different space.
And as you actually grow
with more applications,
you want to have some
way of aggregating the IP
space to those, because
it makes it so much easier
to communicate to those
when you have a way
to aggregate how
you're referring
to them in the networking.
MARK MANDEL: I guess then
that means that, OK, so yeah,
if you have one set of
services or one application
that you just want to
make sure will never ever
talk to another set of
services or an application--
INES ENVID: That's right.
MARK MANDEL: --for anything,
like just a very particular
path through, that's
just another layer
of network security that you
can put in front of stuff.
INES ENVID: That's correct.
And the way it helps
is, again, when
you're talking about
which applications
can talk with your on-premises,
which applications can talk
with each other, you usually
express those policies
in terms of IP ranges.
So if you map your applications
to those IP ranges,
then it makes sense to actually
then express those policies,
based on those IP ranges
and you can map it easily.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Something very related
to the IP ranges
and how you define rules on top
of that is you can also define
rules on top of labels, right?
You can say, oh, I'm going to
type all these virtual machines
with labels saying,
these are web servers,
and then all of the others
saying, oh, these are,
I don't know, MySQL
instances or whatever.
And then you can say, a web
server cannot talk to other web
servers, because why could they?
Is that kind of the
same power as IP ranges?
Do we have it just
for convenience
or is there actually
a specific use case
that we should keep in mind?
INES ENVID: Yeah, that's
a very good question.
So we want to use as much
flexibility as possible, where
we're actually giving
the user the policies.
So the way they actually
express the communication rules,
it could be with IP ranges, but
you can use metadata in order
to make it even more flexible.
So the labels are metadata
that apply to specific VMs,
so that when you express
who can talk with who,
if you have more granularity
that cannot be expressed with
IP ranges, you still have
the possibility of doing that
by applying metadata to the
specific instances that you
want to secure the
communication with.
So it gives you
yet another layer
of flexibility on
top of the IP ranges
on how you actually
express your policies.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Cool.
So we talk a lot about, at
Google Cloud, particularly,
hybrid cloud.
Officially, on-prem with
cloud providers, networking
would seem like that's
a big part of that,
making sure we have
secure communication
between your on-premise
systems and what
we have running in the cloud.
What do we have that
enables us to do that?
How would that work?
How does that happen?
INES ENVID: Yeah, so
there's many different ways
of communicating
with on-premises.
Usually, when you're
communicating privately
to on-premises, you want to
have some security as well.
So once you actually
cross the internet, if you
have certain applications
living in Google Cloud
and you still have
certain applications that
live on your infrastructure
and your premises,
once you start
communicating them,
you obviously need to go through
internet to build that bridge.
So there are several techniques.
One of the most popular
is to use IPsec tunnels,
so BPS in order to provide
that secure communication.
So we offer completely
managed VPN building
on top of IPsec that can connect
your BPC, your sandbox, so
specifically your
sandbox then, to make
sure it's only your
application who can actually
talk with your on-premises.
And we provide capabilities
of up to a [INAUDIBLE]
per second IPsec tunnels that
can be actually horizontally
scaled, so that you can actually
build bandwidth on top of that.
There are other ways of
delivering that communication
between prem and Google.
And there are many
applications these days,
as well, like the more
modern applications,
they actually have
application-level security.
So they usually have SSL as
part of their application
communication.
So some of the
users might decide
that they don't need
the transport security,
and they use the
application instead.
Doing that, you can just have
a regular pairing agreement
with Google or you can actually,
if you are a smaller user,
you can pair with any carrier,
so that you don't actually
need to maintain your own
ASN and there's a [? node ?]
that you need to maintain.
So pairing with Google comes
with certain requirements.
So for smaller users, you
just compare with any carrier.
We have plenty of agreements and
have that communication plane.
And then on top of that, you can
either use IPsec, as we talked,
or you can build your
applications secure
and just communicate
through SSL.
MARK MANDEL: We also have this
thing called Cloud Router.
I don't understand
what it does, but it
seems to be doing, like,
kind of related to what
it is that we do here, in
terms of talking about on-prem,
because it does do stuff over
Cloud VPN, but I-- like I said,
this networking
stuff confuses me.
So I'm very happy here and I
can ask really dumb questions.
INES ENVID: Yeah.
So once you communicate
to on-premises,
you have certain workloads that
get represented by prefixes
in your VPC and then you
have certain applications
that get represented by
prefixes in your on-premises.
So in order for
those two prefixes
to actually be able
to reach each other--
MARK MANDEL: What do
you mean by prefixes?
INES ENVID: IP.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, OK.
Got it.
INES ENVID: IP ranges.
So in order for those IP ranges
to be able to reach each other,
you need to set up routes
and then you need to say,
my IP range 1 needs to
be sent to my IP range 2,
and the other way around.
So you could always
hard-code that
and say, like, all the traffic
destined to my IP range 2,
I am going to send it with
the next hub, this tunnel,
then you're done,
But then what happens
if you then add an IP range 3?
Then you need to
go and remember you
need to configure
another route, otherwise
you won't be able
to communicate.
So what Cloud Router provides
is dynamic advertisement
of those routes,
so then those can
be seen from on-premises as
reachable through the tunnel,
so then you don't really
need to worry about reaching
your applications across.
So it is built with
BEP capabilities
or dynamic routing
protocol, and then it
allows you to have a lot more
automated way to communicate
in your environments.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I have one last
question, which
is, OK, so I just
started-- I have
my virtual machines running.
I just started them.
And I am running, whatever,
Fortress or something
like that.
I have my database and
one single web server.
What is the first thing I
should take into account?
Or what is the
resource that I should
start reading to make
sure that what I'm doing
is not incredibly wrong
and I'm going to be
hacked in less than a minute?
INES ENVID: So
you want to set up
just a simple VM into your
network to run an applications.
So a very simple setup.
So first thing,
you start the VM.
You don't configure
it with public IP,
if you don't really have to.
So just make it private.
When you configure
your VM, you're
going to have your
capability so,
selecting whether you
want to actually locate
a public IP or not.
You want to add metadatas with
[INAUDIBLE] you want to set up
a specific rules for that
specific workload that
might be distinct from others
that ping your own subnetwork.
So you configure those on
your VM, because then based on
that, you can actually
set up policies
that get associated to that.
Then you make it
part of a subnetwork.
So your subnetwork is
going to define from which
IP range it gets located.
Is it private?
And you're pretty much
set up for your VM.
Now what you need to do is to
start building your firewall
rules on top of that.
So what you're
going to say is now
set that this specific VM
can only receive traffic
from source 1111, because
that is a trusted application,
while all the rest, I'll block.
So actually, by default,
we block all the traffic.
And if you want to
talk with anyone,
you need to actually
go and open it
up so that you can talk
with your application.
So you will build that firewall.
You can say, apply only to this
label, which is the metadata
that you set up in your VM.
And at that point, you are
pretty much up and running.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
We are pretty much
running out of time.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, very much so.
In fact--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But
is there anything
else, that you would like to
mention something, some topic
that we might have forgotten?
INES ENVID: Not really.
I think one of
the things that we
are most proud of with
Google networking is really
the amazing infrastructure
that is sitting behind.
So it is the performance,
the type of throughput
that we have for
communicating to VMs.
Like, for instance,
within a cluster,
we can have up to 14
kilobit per second,
which is pretty amazing.
The latency, we can reach
around 100 microseconds.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That is
slightly better than my Wi-Fi.
INES ENVID: So it is, in
terms of performance, latency,
it is definitely
top-class network.
And leveraging on that,
then are all the policies
that we talk about,
so then it helps
you to have the perception
that you are just
unique in that infrastructure
and that you aren't just
operating your own
environment, well, you
are having all these
amazing capabilities
and access to storage.
And if you need to spin
100 more instances,
you don't need to worry
about buying more servers,
and then all the sudden, you
get the same great capabilities
that you had in the first
instance that you built.
So I think this is one of the
biggest assets of Google Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
What you were saying
before, building
on the shoulder of giants--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--same topic again.
Yeah, wonderful.
MARK MANDEL: All right.
Well, thank you, Ines.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
We really appreciate
you taking the time
to come and have a chat with us.
INES ENVID: Oh, thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you very much.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
so much to Ines Envid
for joining us today.
First of all, I hope I
pronounced your name correctly.
And second of all, it
was a great conversation.
I'm definitely
going to get stuck
into the networking tools that
we were talking about today
and looking at how I can
lock down all my services,
and my VMs, and everything else
that I run inside the cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I think that it really
made sense to have such an
episode after the cloud abuse.
Cloud abuse, it was
mainly about, yeah,
if you have issues with abuse,
probably you're being hacked.
So this one is, don't get hacked
and there's how to avoid it.
So yeah, very interesting.
Lots of documentation,
so check the show notes.
Definitely there's going to be
a lot of links to cool things
that you should probably
take into account if you
are the one responsible for
the security in your network.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So to
finish with the episode,
we have one more
network thing, which
is the question of the week.
Is it coming from Luna?
MARK MANDEL: It is coming from
Luna, one of the good people
who hang out on our Slack
channel for Google Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, she's cool.
Hello, Luna.
So yeah, she sent a question
that I did not understand much
about it, but to be honest, I
actually did not know, but OK.
So there's the thing that
some of you might know,
which is so you have a request
that-- an HTTP request that
goes through a proxy-- ah,
sorry, through a proxy,
through a load
balancer, and when
you get it, the IP of the
packet that you receive actually
is the origin is the load
balancer, not the customer that
actually sent you the request.
But there is this
thing that allows
you to know what is the
actual origin, which
is included as a header in the
request, and that is for HTTP.
But what about TCP?
TCP does not have headers?
MARK MANDEL: No.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
how do you do that?
MARK MANDEL: So it's
an interesting one.
So say you're-- classic example
is you're building a game
or something, like you
have a WebSocket connection
or something that is
purely TCP-based, right?
You're not doing HTTP.
But you want to know
where your originating IP
address is from and,
again, same issue, right?
Your network load
balancer is going
to be the one that's the
IP you're going to see.
So exactly like you would have,
say, an X-Forwarded header
with HTTP, there's a thing
called the Proxy Protocol
that is built exactly for this.
So the Proxy Protocol we'll
have in the show notes.
You can read all about it, but
it's basically a convenient way
to safely transport sort
of connection information
across a TCP connection.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I can use
that on my traditional TCP load
balancer?
MARK MANDEL: So that's
the interesting question.
So we have a network
load balancer.
Unfortunately, it doesn't
support the Proxy Protocol.
That's the standard network
load balancer, which
is a regional load balancer.
But we do have a TCP
SSL load balancer.
That's a load balancer
that will terminate
an SSL connection,
which you should
be using, because SSL, good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: SSL--
MARK MANDEL: Secure, yay.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
--is always good.
MARK MANDEL: And not
only is it not regional,
it is global, which
is also great.
But one thing it
does do is it does
support the Proxy Protocol.
So if you want to be able to
send that information across,
it will do that for
you quite easily, which
is super, super, super cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very nice.
Yeah, I was reading the
documentation, which
we will link from the
show notes, as usual,
and yeah, it looks
like it's very simple.
So nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
really straightforward to use.
You can even update the Proxy
Protocol header for the proxy
you like right in the
command line tools
or through the development
console as well.
So that's information you
want to go send across,
use an SSL load
balancer, and it's
global, which is fantastic, and
it'll do exactly what you need.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So before we finish, what
are you going to be doing?
Are you traveling somewhere?
MARK MANDEL: I am traveling.
I will be at
CONNECT.TECH in Atlanta,
literally, the day
after this episode airs.
And then later in the
month, I will be at Gameacon
in Atlantic City.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
Very nice.
I'll be hanging out around here,
working on videos and stuff
like that, and I will
be running office hours
in the Launchpad, which we
should very quickly mention.
It's a new space where
you can come and learn
things about Google
Cloud platform,
and Android, and basically
anything in San Francisco.
So if you are a local,
come check it out.
I'll be there on Tuesday
25th of October from 9:00 AM
to 1:00 PM.
So come ask questions
if you have any.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, if you
want to learn about Go
and Cloud and all the things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and after that, of course,
I'll be going to Brazil
for GopherCon Brasil.
Right.
Sorry about that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Got any new Just for
Func episodes coming out?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, I recorded
it for the third time in a row,
and I think this time
it actually worked out.
MARK MANDEL: This
time it will work out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I'm editing.
So probably by the time
this episode is out,
there will be also another
episode of Just for Func
out, right on time.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Francesc, thank
you so much for joining
me yet again this week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank
you, Mark, and thank
you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: All right then.
See you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]